[Music]
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world it's not
people like you
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a superhuman law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still got to deal with it
your transformations are triggered by
anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh
it feels like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die
yes yes yes
no
no
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
[Music]
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go